The term data science is actually pretty new to me
as well, even though now I think about it, I have
been doing data science since the day I was at
in Taiwan doing a Masters in, in speech recognition. The way
we would understand speech is to collect a lot of
data and understand how to model things like a phoneme in
speech. And how to understand you know, people's language processing
requires a lot of data collection as well. And at Google,
which is a company that collects a lot of data, I also did personalization
there which requires a lot of data
going in, you know, understanding a person's behavior.
So, that to me is data science. Using data to build a useful model or
to understand a particular pattern that is
useful, then later on, for other software applications.